YouTube's revenue is declining for the
first time in history for three straight
quarters between the middle of 2022 and
the first quarter of 2023 Google saw
overall YouTube ad Revenue decline to
their credit YouTube ad Revenue did
start growing again in Q2 of 2023 and we
may see another positive quarter in Q3
but whether Q3 is positive or not the
larger concern Still Remains has YouTube
ad Revenue reached its peak take a look
at this graph for example between 2017
and 2021 YouTube ad Revenue nearly
quadrupled but from 2021 to 2022 ad
revenu stayed basically the same and
with 2023 Revenue estimates coming in at
just over 30 billion do it looks like
YouTube is in for another year of near
zero Revenue growth most of Wall Street
has written off this decline as just
YouTube maturing and the ad Market
softening due to high inflation and
recession fears but I think there is
actually a much more interesting Factor
at play YouTube shorts ever since short
form content started blowing up on Tik
Tok every social media platform has
wanted a piece of the pie including
YouTube who launched shorts since
September of 2020 from a market share
perspective this was very much a smart
move as Tik Tok was starting to eat into
YouTube's watch time and user engagement
but from a more nuanced perspective this
may have actually been a massive step
backwards in terms of Revenue and
financials and if you don't believe me
just take it from Zuckerberg himself
earlier this year Zuckerberg confirmed
that people watching Instagram reals
instead of scrolling through the main
feed was costing the company 500 million
do worth of Revenue every single quarter
and that's just comparing the Instagram
feed to shorts this Revenue disparity is
likely far larger When comparing ful
length videos with shorts and to make
things worse it seems that shorts are
only growing in popularity so is YouTube
cannibalizing their own Revenue with
short form content and what does this
mean for the long-term profitability of
[Music]
YouTube YouTube is clearly struggling
due to the shifting video landscape just
like investors who are struggling due to
a shifting investing landscape High
interest rates have destroyed risk on
assets like growth stocks and crypto
over the past 2 years and to make things
worse High inflation has been eating
away at people's cash savings as well
and that's why we wanted to create a new
platform that would allow retail
investors to adapt to the changing
investing landscape with the help of
bonds with our platform Silo you can
invest in government and corporate bonds
which are currently generating
historically high yields of 4 to 7% all
with the safety of $500,000 in sipc
insurance and 2. $5 million in FDIC
insurance this is precisely what all of
the big tech companies and big name
investors have been doing for decades
with hundreds of billions of dollars so
if you would like to do the same thing
please consider checking out Silo in the
description below but anyway you're
probably thinking there's no way that
shorts revenue is all that much worse
than long form Revenue right well I've
got exact numbers and it's bad on this
channel the average RPM for long form
content is usually right around $5
meaning that 1,000 views generates $5
worth of Revenue now do you want to
guess what the RPM is for short form
content maybe a do maybe 50 well it's
actually 6 cents and that's the highest
I've ever seen it usually it's at 5
cents so right off the bat short form
Revenue per view is about 100 times less
but that's not exactly a fair comparison
because long form views and short form
views aren't exactly equal you see ad
Revenue has less to do with views and
more to do with watch time if you're
watching shorts and you see an ad every
10 shorts then each shorts view is only
worth one tenth of an ad impression if
you're watching a 45 minute long
magnetes media documentary and there's
an ad every 3 minutes however well then
each view could be worth as much as 15
ad impressions of course there's more
variables at play like average watch
time and topic and seasonality and all
of that but that's the general idea
shorts earn less per view because each
shorts view is less valuable than each
long form view but even when we account
for this shorts end up with far less
Revenue per minute of watch time let's
take this channel again for example with
long form content this channel gets just
over 6 minutes in average view duration
this means that 1,000 views translates
to 6,000 minutes of watch time and $5
worth of AD Revenue in other words words
$1 worth of AD revenue is roughly
equivalent to 1,200 minutes of watch
time when it comes to long form content
in terms of short form content the
average short on this channel gets about
30 seconds worth of average view
duration this means that 1,000 shorts
views translates to 500 minutes of watch
time and 6 cents worth of AD Revenue in
other words $1 worth of AD revenue is
equivalent to over 8,000 minutes of
watch time when it comes to short form
content that's nearly seven times less
than long form content and if we apply
this math to the entirety of YouTube
Things become ugly pretty quickly every
day YouTube pulls in over a billion
hours of watch time if all of this watch
time was from long- form content YouTube
would generate roughly $18 billion worth
of AD Revenue every single year if all
of this watch time was from short form
content however YouTube would only
generate about $2.6 billion worth of AD
revenue or over $15 billion less I think
you can see how promoting shorts could
have a massive impact on YouTube's Top
Line Zuckerberg realized this months ago
and that's why meta stopped paying
bonuses to reals creators it's really
quite counterproductive if you think
about it meta was literally paying creat
to make content that would make meta far
less money yeah no wonder they stopped
but it's not as easy for YouTube for
Instagram their bread and butter is
pictures so not emphasizing short form
videos isn't a big deal for YouTube
however bread and butter is videos so
not emphasizing the new trend with
videos is a big deal so YouTube is
caught in this awkward catch22 situation
they have to promote shorts to remain
competitive and retain watch time
against Tik Tok but at the same time
promoting shorts is also directly
leading to substantially less revenue
for the platform so what exactly is the
solution
[Music]
the reality is that there is no simple
solution to this situation so YouTube is
simply trying their best to keep things
moving forward from three angles
starting with the doubling down on long
form content when one part of your
business isn't doing as well one
solution is to double down on the part
of your business that is doing well and
have this part of the business make up
for the other part and it seems that
this is exactly what YouTube is doing
with long form content I know a lot of
you won't like this but YouTube is
moving towards showing more ads on long
form content the most recent of these
changes is an update to add control for
creators as you may know creators
currently have the control to choose
between pre-roll post-roll skippable and
non-skippable ads but starting in
November creators will only have the
option to turn pre-roll and post-roll
ads on or off and it will be up to
YouTube to decide whether it's skippable
or non-skippable and whether it appears
before or after a video or both moving
forward YouTube is also introducing a
new Option when it comes to midual ads
called manual plus automatic essentially
this option allows creators to manually
Place midr ads throughout the video and
YouTube to show even more ads throughout
the video on top of that whenever they
want if you ask YouTube about these
policy changes they'll probably say
something like these policy changes are
meant to make the YouTube ad experience
more refined and enjoyable but that's
just code for we're taking more control
over ads so that we can optimize their
placement and length to maximize revenue
and this is just the most recent
development in YouTube's monetization
effort YouTube has been rolling out such
changes this entire year for example
they have become much more serious when
it comes to blocking ad block they've
been experimenting with 30-second ads on
YouTube TV and they have even gone as
far as stopping video playback for users
with ad block so YouTube is very much
doubling down on long form monetization
but that's only half the story at the
same time YouTube is also trying their
best to convince advertisers to give
short form content a try one of the main
reasons that shorts ad revenue is so
horrendous is because advertisers are
quite hesitant when it comes to short
form advertising for one a lot of them
aren't familiar with how to craft short
formats that convert but honestly that's
something that they can figure out by
just hiring the right people the larger
issue is that they view short from
content as less than and it's no wonder
why most short form content is cringy
brain dead useless dumb entertainment
that you forget within a matter of
minutes so advertising next to this sort
of content isn't exactly ideal but
here's the thing social media ads in
general used to be viewed in the same
light 10 to 15 years ago and that's why
social media marketing was way cheaper
than traditional TV marketing but over
time some more Progressive companies
stepped forward experimented with social
media marketing and showed the entire
world just how effective it could be and
today many niches on YouTube like
finance and Entrepreneurship demand the
same cpms as Prime Time television and
YouTube is hoping that with time
advertisers will realize that it's the
same thing with short form content but
realistically speaking it'll take
several years for such a shift to happen
not to mention all of this still leaves
YouTube vulnerable to the next shift in
video media whether that's AR or VR or
whatever else and that's precisely Why
YouTube is heavily leaning into strategy
number
three optimizing long form monetization
and promoting short form monetization is
great and all but what YouTube really
wants is independence from all of this
when YouTube first came out it was just
a fun platform where people shared
simple videos that they made made
themselves or with their friends and
that still exists on one side of YouTube
but the more popular side of YouTube is
filled with the Mr beasts and Marcus
brownley and Good Mythical mornings of
the world and all of these guys are just
straight up Production Studios even
creators who seem more relaxed like Ryan
Tran really AR you know the saying it
takes effort to seem effortless well
that's exactly what's going on there and
as all these creators evolved so did the
audience back in the day you YouTube was
something that people would use to fill
up free time today YouTube is something
that hundreds of millions of people use
as their primary form of entertainment
so it's not far-fetched for YouTube to
want all of these people to directly pay
for their use of the platform which
brings us into YouTube premium YouTube
currently has a total of 2 billion
monthly active users out of which 80
million are already paid subscribers so
right off the bat YouTube is doing
pretty well when it comes to to pay
subscribers but it's actually even
better than it looks here's the thing
while it's cool that YouTube reaches 2
billion people every month most of these
people aren't really serious users most
of them probably just watch a video here
and there and that's why it's far more
important to look at daily active users
YouTube currently stands at 122 million
daily active users of course not every
single core user is going to use YouTube
every single day so YouTube's core user
base is likely around 200 to 300 million
people given that 80 million of these
people are already paying YouTube has
already converted 25 to 40% of their
core user base into paid subscribers so
their primary goal moving forward would
be to convert the rest this however puts
them in a bit of a tricky situation
YouTube needs to make ads annoying
enough such that all of their core user
base whiches the premium but not so
annoying that they bleed watch time to
Tik Tok and meta and this is what all of
YouTube's recent moves have been all
about blocking ad block increasing ad
length and reducing Creator control over
ads it's all about striking the perfect
balance to maximize YouTube premium
users while still keeping YouTube free
and accessible to Casual viewers this
has been the play for a few years now
but now that they're starting to feel
the pain of declining Revenue the
pressure is on as they go all in on
trying to free themselves from their
dependency on ad Revenue speaking of
dependency if you'd like to free
yourself from from your job by investing
for the long term please consider
checking out Silo in the description
below but until then I'm Hari and I'll
see you guys on the next
[Music]
one